[Music]
what's up guys welcome to this week's
winners on a Wednesday that is a little
bit different because we have the
finalists to the eviction I'm sure
everybody that watched it will say this
you did so Wow like yeah you were the
only person that never lost a sniper
challenge
no I didn't when it was no money down
one I said to the boys because it was me
and three boys and I said look guys I
haven't lost challenge and we're not
losing this one I say I can't I said I
don't want to go in that boardroom some
people said this that what's the why do
you care about the 20 grand if the
eviction people know how to find
properties without easing money and
conjoint venture I can do you Renteria
yeah what's the problem and whilst it's
annoying when people say oh yeah shut up
yeah 20 pounds 20 grand right yeah and
it can fast-track it can help
yeah but he's awesome yeah but there is
some truth in that
would you agree yeah no I totally agree
I think the reason why I was so pent up
on it and the reason why I was so
invested in it is what you just said
fast track
it's that yes you're right you can deal
sauce you can do bits and bobs and you
can do that but you basically Bank
transferred someone twenty thousand
pounds in ten in ten seconds
like that's 20 grand in ten seconds and
then that's it fast track and I said I
said Tanzania and I said so covered well
other people but I don't I don't have
any doubt that I could get that twenty
thousand pounds just take me longer and
I don't want to get to where I want to
get and I want to get there now and you
know what you can do with 20 grams yes
you know I mean when did you join the
Academy about four months ago February
February so okay few months back yeah
since then even before the eviction yeah
and some remarkable things why don't you
just tell us a bit about your background
prior to the eviction but after the
Academy yeah okay so prior to the
eviction and I basically worked
full-time and solicitor and I worked in
like property litigation so I was
actually dealing like mortgage
repossessions and claims against the
bank so I had a bit of a general
consensus about property and I'd always
really liked it but I just never got
involved I was part of that same sort of
thought process you need money to buy a
second house and you need to do this and
that
and anyway a couple of a couple of years
ago my dad got prostate cancer and he's
all fine now and everything but it kind
of triggered something in my head where
I was like like life's too short
life's too short to go to work 9:00 to
5:00 to work like a dog get paid for
work that you don't do and things like
that and then it all started building up
inside me I qualified as a solicitor
that's what I wanted to do and I was on
the train and I basically saw facebook
video Facebook out of you and I watch
more of your videos and and then I just
kind of just jump full-blown in it quit
my job and phrase with no money I had no
money but you quit your job yes on the
basis of someone selling you a dream a
dream yeah and what I done is basically
I worked really really quickly I got a
service accommodation business up and
running
I had three prophecies operating in
Cambridge and I worked out that I had a
three month notice period and by the
time that I'd ended my three-month
notice period I'd be making enough money
to cover my bills and liability yeah
it's going good it's going really really
good so I what done is I've decided to
kind of split what I'm doing personally
so I've got a service accommodation
business but instead of investing all my
time and money in that I'm now there's
property sourcing so that is now running
in the background so prior to the
eviction then you were basically kind of
financially free already yes
just just but but the fight was yeah I
think it's financial freedom sometimes
people think when you say financial
freedom yeah oh you got all the money
you know no no no freedom is having them
exactly what you need yeah on a
recurring property basis yes which which
which is great but at that point and
that's one of the reasons why you were
asked to be on the eviction because we
knew that you had a lot of potential
yeah things like that but man you
seriously killed it so tell us after the
eviction yeah loads loads of stuff and
so in terms of like the rent I say
business that I've got I got a joint
venture partner and they paid for all
refurbs to the house and they're also
taking over management so and I agree to
profit share with them it's completely
hands-off and it works out that actually
I don't lose any money from that because
they've refurbed it they've upped the
value of
so I'm actually going to make more money
than what I was making before and it's
completely hands off of me that's
incredible that's basically just to kind
of carry forward yeah as you've said
look you put the money in yep and then
you're not even do the work no do the
work they did all the work so you put
the money in you do the work but just
because I found the deal I want to get a
share each month on that book and it's
already operating I've already got it
for between three to five years
I said I'll profit share with you a
small profit share and you just deal
with it all and I thought I did exactly
and and do you know where I learnt that
from the eviction I genuinely learned
that so one of the I learned it from
Alastair actually and and it was when I
was talking about is when he came to
Cambridge to see about the apartments
and things and he was like he was
floating different things around with me
and I said I've got my I've got like
somebody a management company that
really want to go in and rjv on these
apartments and he was like well what
does that mean and I was like well you
know there will it's sort of go Hoss and
he was like women it so you could go
half on these apartments put in less
money and still get benefit from them
and I was like I could do and so I took
that idea away and I put it in my own
business yeah talk to me through some of
the deals because some of the deals that
you've been finding in Wales yeah I've
just mental I've even wanted to strangle
you
I'm really I'm a little bit gutted
because this has been a property that so
my background is when two essays rent to
rent okay I know nothing really about by
refurb refinance all that type of thing
which is why the eviction was soem
valuable to me because I'm surrounded by
people that were doing things like that
like Anthony for instance has been a
plethora of like information to me and
I'll tell you a little bit about that
later but yeah so I found the property
in Wales it was on the market for 68
thousand pounds completely been ripped
out there's nothing in it it needs a new
kitchen it needs a new bathroom but it's
down to its bare bones and I looked at
it I thought there's so much potential
here and I managed to get the asking
price down to 58 58 three-bedroom house
and one a couple of doors down sold for
95 and it's smaller spend 15 grand or
whatever on it 15 to 17 and a half grand
refurb that's a refinance it or sell it
at a hundred yep which would be easy
money you can pull out all your money
and the best thing is I had a bill to go
around and look at it and he priced
everything up for me I had everything in
place I just didn't have the investment
money which I'm gutted about because I
said do you want to JV with me on this I
know so yeah so basically what I ended
up doing was I needed I needed cash in
the bank I sold on the deal and I split
split the fees with someone and so
clever as well is I've noticed that you
often you sell deals but you don't
actually sell them no ask them to a deal
sorcerer yeah who then sells them and
then you just constantly take all this
it's less work and it's it's less money
but it's less work which means that you
can do it more times
yeah so basically I was also telling you
a little bit earlier so other stuff that
I've done since the eviction is I've
actually gone into I've gone into
business with James Anthony and John so
now that everything's out I can I can do
it like this so in the third episode
there no money down what we found
well I found to rent two SI apartments
one of them is actually being sourced by
our sir and Ana sold which is great and
how much did you make on that just a
grand or something
1500 yep and that's great ready to go so
that's that's that's going through at
the moment which fantastic but the other
thing that we found I was looking for
rent to sa Apartments on the on the
episode you'll see and that came across
an apartment in Darby in a central
location it's actually great for HMOs
and I called up and I said look I'm
looking for rent to essays and the lady
was like come over for a meeting key
possibly meet us at 6 o'clock and it's
late in the day but we'll come over so
Alastair was like yeah we'll go I said
great fantastic we go we went into this
meeting and none of these guys filmed
anything and we came out and we came out
with five apartments on a lease option
five points on lease option plus um
jewelle property portfolio 300
properties in Darby three hotels below
market value as well coupled with a
brewery that was really random and since
then this same lady has been passing our
stuff back and forward we've had a
portfolio in Wrexham that's come to us
and so we went into business we formed
the company us four unfortunately Ricky
from his own sort of ventures couldn't
commit so James came in instead and so
we've got a company it's called Loa
apartments we wanted to name the company
first it was it is what it is because
that was Ricky saying in the whole
eviction and then we were we were sort
of going should we go eviction and
things and then we're like well we're
gonna do all the business then we
publish and put it a little bit more
streamlined and the eviction it's not
the best name for oh I know I know so
yeah so we're in business over that
which is wicked yeah so those five
partners are now set up and running
another service accommodation units and
they're really right now running right
now at you making off that then
literally went live five days ago and so
they're mainly catered towards a
corporate market but we're estimating
we're probably going to make about after
management costs probably would be happy
with three four hundred pound profit
power apartment yeah and we can split
that between us only problems five five
so it's fifteen hundred pound a month
fifteen fifteen hundred pound a month
and the best thing is right three years
time seven hundred and fifty grand
how much the worth then well the
apartments are worth more now than what
we've agreed below market value that is
incredible
yes so our lease option agree is wicked
you were able to find these deals so
quickly like you had two days it was
meant to hide all these no-money-down
leases rent to rents people were raising
finance it was mentally in the bank I
think when people watch that episode I
think they'll be really surprised by
what you can do with a lot of hard work
and just genuinely just grind in just
grind in like you'll see from the
episode we dragged downstairs to a ppm
meeting in Darby that we had no money to
get in and we were trying to we were
trying to raise deals and things from
people that are going from the
our Park to the building we're trying to
network you didn't have a penny no pay
what you pound to go into anion event
now you're standing in the carport where
it would come out yeah we were like we
were like do your property portfolio ya
got property portfolio B that's
fantastic would you beat me
we raised I think we raised I think we
raised finance from there I can't
remember we raise finance from there or
whether we sold it sold a couple of
deals to kind of yeah like you're crazy
and everyone was acting crazy on the
eviction in the episode I'd see how
brutal the boardrooms were it's horrible
what was it like in the boardrooms it
was horrible it was really not do you
know what you know what's horrible
because like you're very vulnerable when
you're in there and it's literally like
you've got 20 grand that you can win
fight yeah how much do you want it and a
lot of people don't know how to do that
and find that quite uncomfortable to
just back your corner yeah but then you
can apply that to business like you have
to go out there and back you put back
corner when you go and find deals you
have to you have to kind of sometimes
give it a little bit of the big one you
have to go to argue and that's what I
say when I said I it was cursed me when
I said you know you gotta be able to
fight your corner otherwise otherwise
someone else will join you you have to
want it yeah you have stayed but what I
wanted to say is although you're being
crazy and you were stopping people in
the sea and you're pitching people free
from the car park yeah you all had a
grounding even though none of you had
any probably experienced before nicely
but you all had a grounding through
through good property education yeah
which meant that you weren't dangerous
no no and I think one of the things that
we're really big on when we were doing
things like that and when we were
raising finance and whether we could
sell deals is we were always like we're
compliant we know what we're talking
about we come from a place of experience
so for instance lease options I had no
idea about never negotiated on so when
we split people up in in the team
straight off different things we put
people I put people in
they had knowledge of because there's no
point in me going chasing off the lease
options if I've got no knowledge of it
but Anthony and Ricky had a bit of
training on it and they knew a bit about
it so they went and did that and then
John did HMOs yeah and I different two
SATs and some people say to me you know
a lot of people have said to me eyes
unfair you picked people that were
already on the academy but the bottom
line is I wouldn't be able to put 12
people yeah in a house no that hadn't
had any grounding in property before now
and it ended up doing illegal things
probably no so but but so I tried we
tried to pick people the number one
hadn't made any property very long yeah
a few months for yourself literally
number two had no property experience
before going on the crash course and the
Academy or what or whatever kind of
training it was that we were putting on
but number three had at least the basic
ideas they weren't gonna be dangerous I
think I think the dynamic was just right
no I agree with you I've read something
the other day that someone put on there
and I think it's about the first episode
and the pictures and someone you put
well look these guys have had 12 months
of training on the Academy they
shouldn't be more competent than this I
agree with you and what you're saying in
the sense you're saying everybody had a
basic grounding but some people are more
training than others so for instance
like myself a basic training but I've
been on the academy for a couple of
months I hadn't done all the courses so
and two or three maybe max one one one
yeah one being on the academy doesn't
immediately mean yeah of course it is
and you know one of the things I learned
the most and like I keep going back to
it the eviction was so invaluable to me
because I was constantly around 24 hours
around people that are investing in
property that were talking about a
property that had good and bad
experiences and that knowledge is
invaluable you can't put a price on it
having friends that are doing the dough
because most people to everyone talks a
big game oh yeah you know there's some
people talking about doing deals talking
about property but actually being
friends with people that are doing deals
yeah that have you in houses then it's
priceless I'd be honest with you a lot
of people that are going to watch these
videos and then watch your content and
things like that and you say yeah these
people financially free and things like
that and they're like oh it's just a
dream it's not just dream you can
you can generally go out there and make
stuff happen if you want if you want to
go and do it what the bottom line is the
difference between a dream and a plan is
just implementation of course as you
know yes it is a dream when I'm saying
financial freedom it's a dream to most
people cuz it's the people that come on
the crash course and yeah train it and
put in the effort it's not a dream
anymore no it's it's a plan which then
becomes a reality no I agree with you
and I think from the from the
second-to-last episode when they come
round no the last episode when they come
around the CS and stuff and I take
Alastair to my my old work they are
they're lovely lovely people but they're
the epitome of every most people in
society that you should get a job you
should get mortgage you should have a
career and then you should retire and
enjoy your life in 40 years time and a
lot of them spoke about the fact that
what I was doing was not reckless but
kind of bordering on reckless because
I've given up her career as a solicitor
you know a nice paid job I was getting
paid a nice amount of money in Bristol
and and you know and I'd the career in
front of me and a lot of them said about
the fact that it's quite reckless it's
quite out there but I don't see it like
that I see it as me grabbing life by the
balls and doing one yeah absolutely and
you know what I mean I would never
encourage anyone to leave that job to do
property full-time no because it is it
is risky yes but everyone's gotta make
the decision themselves and if you've
got if you've got the knowledge right
and you've got the deals and yet things
in the pipeline which you had yes
exactly
yeah that's keen knowledge so no I don't
advocate anyone trucking in there they
watch this no no no where I was in the
position that I was I yes it was kind of
reckless in a way when you think about
it giving up that type of career but I
had the knowledge to be able to cover my
bills and liabilities per month which
then were free at my time so I could
literally take my income my passive
income all the way up here instead of
just down here the lease option
apartments in Darby are going to be
worth a lot of money in three years time
that's gonna be really cool
but the apartments for instance I was
telling you a little bit about later
earlier sorry and I decided to source
them just to bring in some extra income
yeah the sourcing fee for that was 12 K
so you made 12 grand all right okay what
were the big
lessons that you learned as a result of
you know you journey over the last last
few months but mainly on the eviction I
didn't really enjoy networking when I
was solicitor in fact I hated it I
avoided it all costs but what he taught
me was just be yourself and go out there
put yourself out there and if you put
yourself out there then amazing
opportunities will come if you work hard
and you and you do the work and I didn't
believe it until really the lease option
no-money-down episode I kind of did in
the refurb project because we literally
worked our asses off to get that in at
under 2 K that was mental we worked our
asses off yeah which was wicked but then
the lease option thing and literally
just phoning agents and seeing things
confirmed to me that genuinely you can
do what you want you can make as much
money if you want it's all within your
power so that's what it gave me
confidence it gave me confidence and
knowledge and to put me on a footing
whereby now I know that I could start
from zero money tomorrow and I could if
I wanted to a free ground in the bank
within a week if I found the deal and
sauce there I could wait before I was
like Hana it's a bit hard isn't it no
it's not just go and do it
yeah what what's your strongest reason
why why are you doing this
freedom easy freedom in life to do what
I want every day so yeah money gives me
the freedom to not be able to work full
time but my biggest motivation is like
freedom around doing what I want to do
mainly with my family so I think I think
life's too short and I used to sit sit
at my desk and I used to be like I've
only got three days of annual leave left
like well I want to go and do this and
want to do that now I've got money in
the bank coming up and where I can be
like Shawna got a holiday you want to go
and do that so I'm going to experience
that I can't make that birthday pie or I
can do that or I can go see my dad and
so it gives me freedom it gives me
freedom to make the choices in life what
I want to do and I was adamant and that
I didn't want to be sat behind a desk
for the rest of my life until I retired
I was like no it's not me and people
people at work were like yes you were
you've got 45 years left to work and I
said I will not be sat behind this there
in 45 years time I said you just watch
me and they laughed at me they did they
laughed at me because you're a sinister
what you doing you get you know you can
earn 50 60 70 K you yeah but I could no
more and I could have more time yeah a
lot more fun I know a lot more fun I
love that a lot more fun so yeah that's
my main motivation freedom I love that
tell me what is your big plans then over
the next or six months of being on the
academy and so enough money in the bank
to start my own portfolio easy to be
honest with you and and I want to be
doing some really big deals yeah I want
to do so at the moment we've got a
couple of portfolios that we've got
hands on and we're just trying to get
them over the line and things like that
so keep growing this awesome business so
it takes care of itself
deal with bigger deals build up my own
portfolio refurb my own house so I can
pull some money out of it and I want to
do some I want to do some bits and bobs
and some some cool things with money I
want to invest it in in my family I want
to do bits and bobs like that and I had
a really cool idea I want to set up like
a dumping site no I live in the sticks
so I was like I'll stay there hey but I
worked it out I nearly put it as my
business plan for the eviction
Tulisa parcel and you can get and
wigwams like three grand a pop and they
come and they deliver them like mobile
homes on the lands they don't need any
like running water or anything like that
about how to do it with residential
property you can apply the same skills
to a lot of the stuff yeah some of the
guys like Matt Sims on the academy he's
doing it with campervans rent - rents on
camper vans it's incredible yes it is
it's a it's a business idea that you can
literally apply to anything if you want
it to so yeah I want to do some really
cool things and I want to travel the
world I want to I just want to live life
well you're on track yeah you definitely
were living it up in the eviction in the
past I had the best time I honestly is
one of the best things I've ever done in
my life it was it was funny the only
slight regret I have is the fact that I
had to work with John really bold on a
painting exercise because I'll be honest
with you John is a lovely guy but
everything everything sums up John in
that task from that caption when he just
has paint on his forehead
they missed a part in there we didn't
manage to get filming that Anthony
genuinely gave John a designated task on
the last day because he kept making
blunders he had to stand in front of the
wall to the hairdryer to dry them that
was that was his desk that was his job
that was his job because he was just
paintings not John's strong suit he's
very very intellectual and he's such
clever guy but painting
don't ask John to paint anything won't
be you advice just someone who was
watching this that was really excited to
getting into property from a zero-star
what would their first step and everyone
always says it and it's a cliche but you
need the knowledge I I don't care I
don't care how much money you've got you
need the knowledge because I've spoken
to a lot of people that I've got a lot
of money and they've invested it really
badly because they didn't get the right
knowledge knowledge network I can't
think of a third end but I would say
knowledge network and just speak to
people that are doing it in your area
the amount of great advice I got from
rent to essays from speaking to local
operators and contacts and things so
knowledge and then the rest will take
care of itself you don't need money to
get into property you don't come in from
someone in a legal background
yeah a child person yep that's great
what I mean that's why we put on the
crash course for the crafts course you
don't need - come on across goes on like
that
no everything starts there it does been
on I have been on everything starts at
the crash course no you see right from
the video and we secured those lease
options we danced around the room in the
nunnery and we're like everything starts
on the crash course someone thinking
about those two questions what would
they expect a lot of fun yeah a lot of
energy and yes you do have to go outside
your uu shell if you're quite an insular
person I was insula and like when you're
like high-five the person next year I'm
like oh man I have to touch the person
makes three but you don't buy into it
and it it changed your mindset and if
you allow it to change your mindset then
it will change it will change your life
well yeah 107 well I'm really glad that
you've been through the eviction it's
just right getting to know ya thank you
and I think we have a lifelong
friendship but also it'd be great to do
some deals with you as
I've gotta pass some of those deals
himself well see I think now okay okay
thank you thank you so much for watching
the video that is the reason why I'm
doing this
your success is my oxygen every single
week we've got people becoming
financially free if you'd like to see
more success to that you can do that
right here but what I'd really suggest
is why don't you come and join us at the
property investors crash course come on
on my guest completely free and I'll
personally be there for two days to help
you get started you can see what happens
right here what you'll notice is all of
these stories they all start at the
crash course so come along my guests
can't wait to see you there peace out